[Musique]
il extrait la matière grasse du lait
pour en faire du beurre qu'ils revendent
au prix fort et se retrouve avec de
grandes quantités de lait écrémé
transformé en poudre pour être stockées
mais comment les coulées pour remplacer
la graisse animale s'effondre airs et
engraissés à l'huile de palme une huile
12 fois moins chère que le beurre ce fol
est ensuite exportée en afrique de
l'ouest où il est vendu jusqu'à 30%
moins cher que le local on ne parle
beaucoup de poudre mais pas seulement
dans les poudres dans les yaourts dans
le lait liquide dans le fromage dans
l'ailé condensé on va retrouver une
majorité de produits laitiers vendus en
afrique de l'ouest qui sont à base de
cette poudre de lait
[Musique]
non
on
aujourd'hui si l'europe et de l'afrique
c'est pour sortir de l'insécurité
alimentaire et enfin l'europe est en
train de créer l'insécurité alimentaire
en nous envoyant du lait en poudre dans
la mesure où nous producteurs nous
n'arrivons pas à valoriser notre
production
[Musique]
monde